this is my most brutally honest advice
to my younger self you can beat 99% of
people simply by continuing to work
without needing your immediate reward
this bit is advice to my younger s on
how I work harder you're going to lose
sleep you'll doubt whether it'll work
you'll stress to make ends meet you
won't finish your to-do list you'll
wonder if you made the right call and
have no way to know for years but that's
what hard feels like the other great
reason for working harder is that the
harder you work the more you realize
what you used to think was hard work
isn't even close to what you're capable
of because if you want to know what the
most dangerous money-making combo in the
world it's work ethic and time because
once you real realiz just how much more
work it takes to get from good to Great
you realize you can only be gr at a few
things and you're forced to ignore the
rest the amount of work it takes to be
good negates the ability to be great at
more than one or two things cuz there's
just only so much time it just takes
work shitloads and shitloads of work and
every time I dress it up or cut a corner
I get brutally reminded by life that the
work just needs doing so yes this is
your friendly reminder that it's okay to
work on weekends I used to think that if
I worked on something for a day it was a
lot I was like dude I worked on this for
a whole day that was like a huge amount
of work work and I would say that to
someone to show them how hard I worked
and then it became like I worked on this
for a week and then a month and I would
say now that I can work on the same
project for a year or two years and
that's what like to the books has been
huge projects for me my quickest
shorthand on the shift in work is that I
started counting in hundreds hundreds of
minutes hundreds of hours hundreds of
days towards a specific goal if you
count in hundreds it just automatically
forces you to do a significantly larger
amount of effort just sheer volume of
work I think one of my favorite Parables
about work is that there was an art
class they SP split the class into two
groups and one group they said make the
absolute best pot and turn in one pot
and the other group they said make as
many pots as you possibly can at the end
of the semester the team that had to
make as many pots as soonly possible not
only made more pots but also ended up
making better pots than the one that
spent all of their time trying to make
one I think a lot of people need that
permission to have a lot of shitty first
drafts in order to start working harder
on anything but that's not how I operate
because for me I would rather spend a
lot more time on my first draft so I
don't have to make so many more edits if
if you do it the right way you realize
how many hours you're going to have to
put into something and usually most
people that I feel like haven't done
that level of effort confront the work
and then they get scared about it I have
to find a different way this can't
actually be how people do this that is
how you do it the work just needs doing
and no one's going to do it for you I
started with a normal hourly job and I
think a lot of people do a lot of early
job thoughts or lessons are that when
you show up to work you are working
because you're getting paid to be there
when you start working for yourself
you're not getting paid to be there
you're only getting on what you do I've
gone on vacations with other
entrepreneurs they're like man we had a
crazy workday I was like I was with you
homie like that was not a work these are
off days for me like these aren't like
real work days because work occurred it
to me is not a work day unless I have a
clear output for what I have done or
move forward work didn't happen the
longer you can delay when you need to be
rewarded for the work that you do the
greater the outcome is it's kind of like
a plane taking
off the longer the runway the bigger the
plane and so a lot of people can barely
even get a bottle rocket off the ground
because they have such a short attention
span and such a need for immediate
reward if you feel like you're behind
where you should be by now if you feel
like you're losing if you're not sure
it's going to work there's nothing wrong
with you that is entrepreneurship you're
on the right path you're doing the right
things you're seeing the Milestones
along the way but the Milestones aren't
parades it's uncertainty it's a
Sleepless nice it's not knowing if you
can make payroll it's not even being
sure that the 5 years you put into this
idea is actually going to turn into
something that you'll get credit for
eventually the biggest shift that I had
internally during those harder times was
that I am the output of my work all of
this effort is to create who I want to
become I get to use that as my reward
every day rather than the approval of
strangers sitting in uncertainty is the
feeling of Entrepreneurship you're not
doing it wrong like that's what it feels
like it's kind of this weird dichotomy
of feeling like you never have enough
time but then you also have all the time
in the world the biggest reason that a
lot of entrepreneurs don't succeed is
because they're in a rush the rush is
what creates poor decisions and so they
consistently hop from thing to thing to
thing because they think this thing will
get them there faster by hopping
consistently they guarantee that they'll
never get there and I think we have a
culture that rewards speed because
everybody wants things fast and easy in
$100 Milli offers the book I talk about
value you have a dream outcome and then
you have basically everything that
discounts or multiplies it a discount
would be risk associated with it I want
this thing but I want it to be
guaranteed I want it to be easy and I
want it to be fast and Entrepreneurship
is literally the opposite of that the
dream outcome's there but it is not
guaranteed incredibly hard and takes
forever the problem is that that it's so
compelling to sell people on that and
there's so many more ad dollars that go
into it's fast it's easy and it's
guaranteed that it's really tough to
shift the landscape of the language
around entrepreneurship because there's
just so much money to be made by making
that promise the concept of the the
billionaire who like starts back over
and they're like could he do it again
it's like well of course the problem
with the show is is that they give you
90 days the premise is wrong and I get
why they do it is because they have to
cater to people who think that way which
is most people can you build a million
dollar business in 90 days but it's like
but he could build a much bigger
business in 2 years and that billionaire
would probably never build the business
that he builds on the show so it
actually reinforces the wrong
perspective from a brand Foundation
perspective it's how can I build a
reputation over a long period of time
not necessarily with the intent to
transact but simply to build a
reputation associating myself with these
positive things that takes time for one
lots of people to find out about you and
two for a lot of people to develop a
strong affinity and make multiple
associations with you so that it's
stronger the classic example of that is
somebody who makes content for 5 years
and then launches a product and the
product's immediately a billion dollar
thing well it's not that they made a
billion dollars in a year it's that they
spent 5 years letting the roots go down
for the bamboo tree and then eventually
it shoots up right on the other hand
you've got kind of product based
Foundation software you might take a
long time to code and like write a huge
code based that could go after some big
problem it can be regulatory stuff
because if you want to get into like
banking for example there's lots of
barriers to entry even if you're
starting an e-commerce brand you would
be talking to different manufacturers
you'd be going through prototypes you'd
be trying things out you'd be testing it
in beta groups to get feedback and then
you'd probably have some sort of capital
investment to capitalize your first
inventory run all of those things are
the foundations the reason I like
service businesses for people who are
starting out is that you don't have to
do either of those things but if you had
one or two or both of those things then
you can create something bigger faster
on a longer time Horizon it's actually
the classic example of how long do you
sharpen the axe if someone is doing a
business that they have no leverage
because they built no Foundation they
basically just take whatever ax is given
to them and they just start hacking away
at the tree except in the game of
business the tree might be mile wide and
the axe that you have could be a
lightsaber if you spend enough time
sharpening it even if it took one guy a
year of going from dull axe to
lightsaber he would still catch up at
year two and then from year 2 to 10
doesn't even get close to the other guy
but the problem is that everybody
listens to everyone else who's judging
them on their time rizon like you quit
your job on a employee time rizon your
family is like have you started making
money yet and you're like it's been 2
weeks they're like well yeah this is
when you would normally get a paycheck
your measuring stick has to change when
you get into a different game sometimes
the f fastest way to get to a million a
year isn't the fastest way to get to $10
million a year and to the same degree
the fastest way to get to 10 isn't the
fastest way to go to 100 if we're
measuring effort in terms of stress and
hours per day running a local restaurant
takes the same amount of work as
building an application that could be a
billion dollar application and it might
take you a few years for a restaurant to
build a reputation in the area get
locals coming in hire and train good
talent like it takes a lot of work to do
all that stuff and to the same degree
hiring really good development engineers
and creating a prototype like the actual
work and stress is almost identical it's
almost like you have three slot machines
that you're going up to and they all
cost the same cost but one of them has a
billion dollar payout one has a $10
million payout and one has $100,000
payout and everyone just lines up for
the $100,000 payout the third variable
if we're going to like make this in
terms of Dimensions the next one is how
long are we measuring the payout for the
slot machine we assume that slot
machines pay out immediately but if one
slot machine pays out now one pays out
in a year and one pays out in 5 years
what if the odds were the same but you
only got one coin which one would you do
people will say they would do the
billion dollar one but based on their
behavior they're just standing at the at
the the fast token machine not being
able to break it the fact that you don't
know if it's going to work is exactly
what makes it worth doing it's why
entrepreneurship isn't for the faint of
heart you have to embrace uncertainty
what makes entrepreneurship isn't the
work itself it's actually just not
knowing if the work will work we're
afraid of wasted effort but if it makes
you better then no effort is wasted and
as as long as you can make that
connection you're not going to burn out
you're just doing what it takes the
biggest metal lesson of my entire life
was when I lost everything the first
time I had sold all the gyms and then
that was my Nest Egg for my 5 years of
work even though it was not as much as I
had hoped but it was still something and
then I put that all into the next thing
and then lost it all but after losing it
all I was able to immediately go out and
make $100,000 the next month with
nothing maxing out a credit card to do
it that moment was when I was like oh
like I thought that the gyms were the
thing that I had built but it was my
skills is the thing that I had built I
consider skills income Insurance you
just know that you will be able to make
money people want to invest in the stock
market because they want to have a
retirement if you invest in skills that
is your retirement because you will
always be able to trade them for money
and whether the money is in Bitcoin
cells or dollars you'll always be able
to trade something of value and I'm sure
this is going to piss off the exact same
people that we think it's going to piss
off you don't need a weekend like the
concept is barely 100 years old it's a
modern invention right what you really
need is work that you don't need a
weekend from instead of thinking about
work life balance as like a 7-Day Work
Week think about work life balance as
like on like a 7-year time Horizon and
so like there are seasons of work and
there are seasons of less work my goal
would always be that I just never have
something I want to retire from in some
ways you could say I retired from owning
gyms for a while but I haven't retired
from work I don't think anyone who wants
to live a long life should retire from
work all the people that I know who are
really old they pretty much die when
they stop working I've seen the people
who stay alive the longest have reasons
to stay alive and work is a good one the
problem is that everyone's idea like the
masses who are listening to this their
idea of what work is is not what I'm
talking about theirs is like the soul
sucking work at a job you hate for a
boss that doesn't appreciate you for a
company that doesn't do good in the
world I completely understand why you
would not be motivated to do that and
you would want to get away from that as
soon as possible you'd be amazed at how
much faster you can get to your goals
when you don't go backwards 104 days a
year contrary to what the mediocre
masses will tell you weekends can also
be for work we had a contractor once who
said I quit my job so that I wouldn't
have to work weekends and he was upset
that he had worked a weekend you do not
have an accurate estimation of reality
if you think that starting a business is
going to mean that the first business
you ever start you're not going to work
weekends right now if I started a
business I could take weekends if I
wanted to but I think it's cuz there's a
level of skill you have to get to to get
there a buddy of mine was talking to me
about how he had an employee who was
asking for like 6 weeks of paid vacation
they had like not a lot of experience
was like I need this time he's like well
I tell you what he's like what if I give
you 110 days a year off paid would that
work they were like yeah he's like cool
that's weekends and federal holidays if
you just don't go backwards on weekends
you can move ahead so much faster if you
go out drinking or you do your cheat
days on the weekend then you can undo
all of the work that you're doing in the
rest of the days of the year and be
neutral or even negative at the end of
the year depending on how bad off track
you go during those 104 days from a
business perspective you might get
inquiries over the weekend if you don't
work your leads over the weekend you
start in a deficit you might lose those
sales if you generate income during the
week and then you don't on weekends it's
104 days a year that you're not
generating income out of 365 you're also
going into a deficit that you have to
then make up for in the first two days
so let's say that the two-day negative
has to get offset by two days of
positive then you're really only working
three days now you compare that to
somebody who's either not losing Steam
on the weekends or actually getting
ahead on the weekends that person isn't
moving ahead like twice as fast they're
moving ahead like seven times as fast
and so I think that's the piece that a
lot of people are missing is they'll
look at somebody who's further ahead be
like well this person works like this
it's like well if you work the same
amount as them they're actually going to
keep getting further ahead so you have
to work as much as them to match
probably a little bit more because
they're more skilled at working than you
are and then even more to get ahead
success is the only Revenge as you
expand they shrink into irrelevance as
you get louder no one can hear them you
don't beat them you cast a shadow so big
no one can see them to begin with
because at the end of the day there's no
greater waste of time than justifying
your actions to people who have a life
that you don't want and there's no
amount of pain you can inflict on a
hater that will be more painful than
their own life last part was from Leila
like there is no retaliation there's no
retribution there's no actual Revenge so
I have beaten a lot of business people
in the field people that I saw as
competitors like where it was very clear
we're going head-to-head for a market
what's really weird is that when you
actually win when someone actually goes
out of business it's like not cool you
don't like spit on their corpse you're
just like oh there is a Tipping Point at
some point where you start to gain an
advantage you start to separate from
them but then like they start flailing
and acting erratic and trying to get
ahead and then that further you know
they go down that vicious cycle because
you their hater in their mind or their
competition the biggest mistake in my
career I made because of a competitor
that mistake cost me somewhere in the
neighborhood of $25 million actual money
not like like oh this is an opportunity
that I like I actually lost like $25
million on this and I just swore to
myself that I would never let somebody
else dictate my behavior winners focus
on winning losers focus on winners so
the same thing goes with competitors
winners focus on customers competitors
focus on winners they're always trying
to copy you but because they're trying
to copy you they're not looking at their
customers they're looking at you and so
they're completely distracted they're
not looking at the data source that
matters most first off if anyone ever
copies you you've already won because
they need you you don't need them you
should be afraid when people stop
copying you because it means you've got
nothing and so I see people copying what
I'm doing as a positive sign that I'm on
the right path rather than a distraction
that merits all of my attention getting
redirected to trying to destroy someone
if you walk like downtown in any City
well that building is a $400 million
building and that building is $400
million that's how much money a
billionaire has everything else that's
there is still up for grabs there's so
much out there it's super hard to
comprehend when we had 5,000 plus gyms
in gym launch I think we had 45 gyms in
Atlanta they would be like well there's
another gym down the street I'm like
there's also 1,500 gyms in Atlanta so
the 45 that are all gym launch gyms are
just going to do do better than the
other
1,455 the pie is so much bigger than
people think it is if you feel like you
are the output of your life at the end
of your life who you are is the thing
that is the thing that you became then
competition is good for you like if you
look back at that that person would you
want that person to have no challenges
like if you were at the end of your life
and you looked back would You' be like
I'm glad I overcame no adversity I'm
glad no one ever put me to the test I'm
glad I never got to see what I was truly
capable of I'm glad I never had to risk
it all when the chips were down you
would never say that we just don't like
going through it in the short term but
we do want the outcome of it if you just
accept that that's the price tag for the
person you want to be then you just pay
it willingly my two simple lenses for
friendship number one do they genuinely
root for you when you win number two do
they make you better finding people who
do even one of those two things is rare
both is even rarer which is why they get
the highest title of friend one of the
highest Roi trads in life that you can
make is all the fake friends that you
have for one real friend that has your
back even when all seems lost bonus
points if it's your spouse the rear
people in your life who root for you to
hit your goals are more valuable than
the goals that themselves consider
yourself lucky if you find even one
human who believes in you more than you
do and never let them go when you start
out people are happy for you that you're
doing something but I this is going to
be really [__] up but I actually think
that people are happy that you quit your
job because it counts you out of the
race because the likelihood that you win
is so low and so they're happy because
you're actually taking a step back you
literally take a step back in income
take a step back in status because
you're not doing as well like I went
from a white collar job to being a
personal trainer like it was a big step
back so any of my peer group were like
oh yeah so good that you're doing that
if I had immediately jumped and started
a tech startup and raised $100 million
they probably immediately wouldn't have
been happy for me I think the reason
that you get that Underdog rooting in
the beginning is because you actually
take a step down in status and so their
relative standing actually increases so
they encourage you but then as you come
up your success reminds them of the
dreams that they didn't pursue to begin
with it also reminds them that you
started with probably the same resources
and that's why it's so hard to go home
for a lot of people because everyone who
you grew up with in middle school and
high school you become a glaring example
of what they could have done but didn't
it's what you make them think about
themselves astonishingly more people
know what they should do than claim to
know what they should do there's usually
a voice on some level acting is a
hypothetical punishment they haven't
actually experienced yet for taking an
action that they haven't done yet
because we fear this hypothetical
punishment we don't take the real action
a lot of people just stay stuck there
there was one specific voice that I was
like really afraid of for selling gym
launch because I thought 46 million
wasn't enough that that person would be
impressed and then what I thought about
was like this person is going to prevent
me from like this person's opinion I
like what do I care he can do his own
life what if he does sell his company
for more money than me does that mean I
suck no it just means that like I
decided to do something he decided to do
something I'm only ascribing value to
this person's SP just cuz I know who
they are there's 100, times more people
who I don't know who beating me than the
ones that I do so why would I listen to
this one person unless someone is ahead
of you take their hate as envy and then
disregard it Envy is when you want
something that someone else has jealousy
is when you fear losing something that
you have so if you've got your girl and
some guy comes up you get jealous if
someone has a girl that you wish you had
you experience Envy so Envy is about
something you don't have jealousy about
fear of losing something you do if
people are further behind you then
they're envious of you if someone's
ahead of you then they're afraid that
you're going to take what they have mind
you in either of those scenarios it
doesn't matter I see hate as feedback
nothing more nothing less and I think
feedback is worth taking into
consideration and what level of validity
there is so if someone says hey you
copied my entire business and you've
never met them well you know that that's
not true I had this guy come up to me
saw me on the street randomly he was
like hey man I need to apologize to you
for what I've like really really hated
you for a long time why he's like
because you stole the closer framework
from me and I was like dude I don't know
who the [__] you are he was like let's
be honest like what's the likelihood
that we both came up with the same
acronym and I was like hi you take an
acronym that's for a closer and then you
fit the words I actually went back I
found my first document that had closer
on it and I screenshotted the date and
it was before he had started selling he
squashed it and I was like you're
copying me [__] I said it
jokingly cuz I don't give a [__] the
hates feedback if I'm getting data from
the environment it's data it's not good
or bad it just is if everybody ahead of
you is afraid that you're going to beat
them that's probably decent data if
everybody behind you is envious of where
you're at that's probably decent data to
know if people are all trying to sue you
at the same time for something then
maybe there's something there that you
shouldn't have done that you did it's
the second layer of judgment is the one
that everyone gets in trouble with this
thing happened now I'm going to ascribe
meaning to it what does the hate mean
doesn't mean anything it's just feedback
and then you take the data and do
whatever you want with it sadness comes
from a lack of options which is why it
feels like hopelessness anxiety comes
from many options but a lack of
priorities which is why it feels like
paralysis looking everywhere but moving
nowhere solve sadness with knowledge and
anxiety with a decision understanding
this changed my life let's say somebody
gets really depressed cuz they get laid
off why are they sad because they have a
perceived lack of options if I have five
job offers on my table am I sad that I
got laid off because my job offers are
better than one that I just left no now
if I had 100 options on the table I
might have anxiety because I have too
many options and I don't know which one
to do it's a perceived lack of options
with sadness you don't know what to do
because you don't know anything to do
with anxiety you don't know which to do
disappointment is when an expectation
was UNM you neither change your
expectations or change reality the stoic
frame for that is that you imagine all
the things that could have gone worse I
mean there's a lot of frames but that's
one of them the other one is that you
imagine that that thing happens a
thousand times in a row what would you
feel on the thousandth time probably
nothing why because you'd already
adjusted your expectations and if you
already adjusted your expectations then
you can adjust them now Buddhist monks
fundamentally basically do that they
just change nothing externally and only
change internally which is fine but to a
certain degree like I want to benefit
humanity and I don't know how beneficial
that is and to be fair me saying that I
want to do that also creates an
expectation of myself which I could be
let down for so like I do create a
possibility that I am let down by saying
I want to help people and if I don't
help them then I would be disappointed
you can shoot big as long as you don't
make missing mean that you suck I think
that being has been the best goal for me
to pursue because it's the one that's
100% under my control if I have
something that is disappointing that
occurs what type of person do I want to
be in this instance and then what would
that man do and as closely as I can map
my actual Behavior to that person's the
more joy I will experience because I'm
present in doing the things that I think
I should be doing and I can still give
myself kudos for how well I handled a
shitty situation and then end up
deriving Joy from something that
otherwise might have been bad I remember
seeing this quote once I was like if you
follow your own advice you'd already be
way further than you currently are and I
thought about that and I was like yeah I
don't think I need to follow anyone
else's advice I think I should be doing
the things I already know I should be
doing then you just have like kind of
the emotional component of feeling like
you want to maybe release something or
whatever and me being able to talk to my
future version of myself in a dialogue
format allows me to get Grace from a
future version of self and also get
approval from a future version of self
so somebody that I esteem higher than
myself is future may who's hopefully
better and his judgment on my current
situation and his advice it tends to be
really good advice the best advice I've
gotten has been from future no one's
afraid of failing they're afraid of what
other people will think of them when
they fail but if they're afraid of that
imagine what those other people think of
you when you're not even trying well the
reality is they're not at all if they
don't have what you want don't listen to
what they say having what you want is a
really easy evidence Point that's high
likelihood basically it decreases the
risk of whatever advice they're
providing that's not a perfect frame cuz
there are amazing Olympic coaches that
never won the goal the fastest way to
move forward in life is listen to people
who can give you advice that can get you
there faster so not having to suffer and
experience and waste all that time and
back step to learn the lesson to move
forward and So the faster you can avoid
those lessons and just keep moving
forward the faster you move but the
problem is we don't know who to trust
and so I have made seven levels of how I
weigh advice that have served me well at
the lowest level number seven comments
on social media which is basically
comments from strangers who don't know
me and don't have what I want number six
people giving their two cents who do
know me but don't have what I want
number five someone who knows me and
knows someone who went to where I'm
trying to go number four someone who's
been there number three someone who took
someone else there number two someone
who took someone just like me to exactly
where I want to go and number one
someone who has been there took someone
else there just like me multiple times
do I trust somebody who's taking someone
else there because I am the someone else
more than someone who's only taking
themselves there cuz if someone's taking
someone else there then I could slot in
and there's a likely they could do it
again if they've only taken themselves
there and not taken anyone else there
then they might not be a very good
teacher which happens all the time
Michael Jordan has an insane record
playing basketball has a very poor
record owning a basketball team I'm big
on give give give until they ask right
especially if you're starting out the
best thing to do is give away step for
free for multiple reasons one because
you probably suck because you haven't
done it yet and it's a gift if someone
allows you to work for them because you
have a chance at providing value and
from there you can leverage that into
testimonials referrals and potentially
even a paying customer they might if you
continue to provide this value for free
eventually say hey I've got too many
people providing for free I have too
much Demand on my time at price of free
and I can go to 20% of the price that I
want to go to and if everyone says yes
and you still have demand then you go to
40% of the price and then 60 and then
100 and then then 500% right and you
keep going but what happens is a lot of
people will Short change that and so I
get DMS every day of people saying Hey I
want to give you value in exchange for
and it's just stop don't tell me what
value you want to give me and what you
want to trade that value for and usually
it's them actually massively
undervaluing my time as though them
making it free to me is somehow more
valuable than me paying for something
like I have tons of money I don't have
tons of time and so it's my much scarcer
resource this kid was like yeah I have a
lot of advice that I think I can give
you on social media and I click over his
profile he's got 100 followers and he
said I'll do it in exchange for a
testimonial and it was just like it was
so blind to reality first off you have
no evidence that you're good second off
it's delusion and so the way to do it
right is to go above and beyond do a ton
of work and then just give it to the
person not in exchange for or an
expectation of but just give it to that
person and then guess what will happen
nothing cuz most times if someone's way
ahead of you they might not want it or
might not need it but you make your best
approximate guess of what they might
need do your best shot at it there's
probably three things that can happen
one most likely nothing happens they
don't respond to you they don't care the
second option is that they see how hard
you worked on something and even though
they don't need that thing everyone one
level up needs people who work hard on
things and then so you still prove how
hard you work by how good the thing that
you give is and so they might have an
opportunity for you not even in in the
main thing but on something else and
then the third and probably the least
least likely but probably the one you
want the most is that they say wow
that's amazing I would love for you to
do that now to be fair most of the
people on my team came from doing that
you roll the dice and people roll the
dice one time with their time and say I
did this work for this one guy and he
didn't immediately hire me on retainer
but did you do it for 100 people if you
give tremendous value to 100 people
you'll be able to make more income than
most jobs in America simply by providing
a tremendous amount of value to 100
business owners one of them or five of
them will respond back and say yes I
would like more work from you or I can
offer you a job I was afraid to charge
people money but I did want them to like
be invested and so I started a nonprofit
called the free training project where I
said if they donated $500,000 the
charity of their choice I would train
them for 12 weeks that's how I got my
first customers but then after the 12
weeks some of them were like I still
want to keep training with you and I was
like hey I'm the charity now I am poor
please help me that's literally it
literally at the end of 12 weeks I was
like I think I want to do this full-time
CU I did it while I still have my job
and then I was like I think I want to do
this full time I hope you guys are okay
with this I like if you could pay me
instead I just kind of like everyone did
no one had any problems with it